and this white house is trying to blame
it all now on vladimir putin here's the
statement that president biden put out
about inflation he said today's
inflation report is a reminder that
america's budgets are being stretched by
price increases and families are
starting to feel the impacts of ainsley
putin's price hike that is the talking
point that we're hearing it's all
vladimir putin none of the policies they
just think we're dumb they just this is
what happens when you're in an
administration you look at whatever the
biggest conflict is whatever the biggest
news story is it happens to be what's
happening in russia right now they think
that oh that's that's great we're going
to take advantage of this we're going to
blame everything on that situation to
divert to redirect so that we're not
blamed for this even though we are not
dumb and we have felt this in our
pocketbooks and our bank accounts
democrats republicans independents
everyone across the country have felt
the inflation have felt food prices
going up our electric bills going up to
fill your gas tank some someone told me
in california it was a hundred bucks for
her mom to fill up her gas tank she
lives in la i mean that's crazy we're
not stupid this has been going on for
more than a year now we saw it happening
as soon as donald trump left and as soon
as joe biden takes office and people
want it fixed and they're going to have
a problem in november at midterms if
they don't solve this problem they can
blame it on everything under the sun but
we know that it is their fault and if
they don't fix it they're going to lose
the elections in november steve ratner
worked for president obama and would not
hear of it or have it like larry summers
has been speaking out when economics has
just been misconstrued and mismessaged
he says well no these are february
numbers and include only a small russia
effect this is biden's inflation and he
needs to own it and they go back to the
1.9 rescue package saying that was
totally unnecessary trump gave you 800
billion which was unnecessary we sent 6
trillion coming out of the pandemic we
just spent 1.4 last night on the omnibus
bill you spend all this money if the
dollars uh dollars just inflate but it's
not going to stop that messaging from
coming out you're exactly right i mean
they they have to think people are dumb
because every single chart
on inflation and on gas prices looks
like that since he took over and yet
they're trying to say just pay attention
to this really little part at the end
and that's what steve ratner put it out
an obama official four days of that of
that consumer price index report are
when the the war was actually going on
the more we pay at the pump the more
they're going to pay in november i'm
steve ducey i'm brian kilmeade and i'm
ainslie earhardt and click here to
subscribe to the fox news youtube page
to catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis